what's happening are y'all good so it's
pretty crazy being up here I can't
believe we pulled this off this fast but
I'm really thankful that you guys have
all came here yeah we have we've sold
about 400 tickets so this place is going
to be pretty crowded throughout the day
but thank you all for coming it feels
like we're in a room full of friends so
I really appreciate the great energy and
by the way my name is Sam par so I'm the
guy who's been emailing the hell out of
you for the past three or four weeks so
it's great to finally meet you and
welcome to hustle con yeah so this is
the second time we posted this event the
first one was last year but a lot of
people don't realize that we didn't
launch this year's web site until june
six which means we sold about 380 so
tickets and still out this big theater
in about seven weeks so again thank you
for being part of this today's really
really going to rock i'm pretty
exhausted today because i was up late
last night i was checking out the guest
list of all the speakers and all the
guests and all you guys and I was pretty
shocked at some of the people we have
here today notice we have founders of
billion-dollar companies all the way
down to interns at small stage startups
and it kind of hit me that what's great
about hustle con is that we bring
together a community of people who are
shamelessly resourceful shockingly
ambitious and scrappy as hell and so if
you took the precious time out of your
day to come here and make please make an
effort and go out of your way to
befriend as many people as possible
absorb as much energy and knowledge as
you can and try to smile as wide as your
face will allow because today's gonna be
a lot of fun so again thank you thank
you for coming and here's how the day is
going to play out we've got 15 speakers
today 10 of them are going to be giving
20-minute talks that are full of
actionable tactics on very specific
topics followed by a five-minute Q&A
session as the 20 minute speakers are
having the talks make your way down over
here to Eric he's going to be near this
exit sign and so as the talks are going
on make your way down if you have a
question and Eric will hand you a mic at
the end of the talk and you could ask
your question but like I said please try
to come down before it's over this way
right when Jess or whatever
whoever speakings done you're ready
queued up to go so it's going to go
really smooth in between each of the 20
minute talks we're going to have five
lightning talks which is when the
speakers have 20 minutes slides that
change automatically every 15 seconds
the topic is the speaker's choice and
the idea is for the speaker to enlighten
us but doing it very very very quickly
also download the bizzy bone app because
it has the schedule and you'll also be
able to get updates on what's going on
and you'll know about if anything
changes last minute and after the event
we're all going to be heading down to
Southern Pacific brewery it's about a
half a mile down the road and we could
have a really big ol kick-ass party so I
hope everyone can make it and also
before we begin huge thanks to a Riley
media they provide breakfast for us this
morning they also have a ton of books
out there and they're throwing a big
conference called strata so if you're
interested in that which you totally
should because awesome go out and talk
to them oh and finally channel 4 and the
you it's a station in the UK they're
doing a documentary and they're looking
for entrepreneurs to pitch their startup
idea they're going to be hanging out in
the lobby it's going to air in the fall
to about 3 million people in Europe so
if you're interested in doing something
like that which you probably are go and
talk to them in the back you'll know who
they are the one of the few people here
that are have a really thick English
accent so are we all ready to get
started so our first speaker is justly
she's the CEO